[Music]
I'm Bonnie and I am a director at
Jubilee I've been with Jubilee for
exactly a year now and I've directed I
think close to 20 videos that's me as
video creators and directors we put a
ton of weight on the comments section of
our videos there can be thousands of
amazing comments but the one critical
hurtful or flat-out hateful one we come
across will be the one that sticks with
us but she was coming listen she's vegan
saying you wag if you're not rude that's
not vegan yeah I hope they don't either
because then that wouldn't be vegan
honey isn't vegan you don't really
consider yourself vegan because aren't
vegan that's not vegan so I decided to
start reaching out to some of our haters
particularly those who have commented on
my own videos okay a big pet peeve of
mine is that people categorize anyone
who criticizes them as vegans someone
saying Erin was really ruined
disrespectful it is not a hater that's
just stating effect she was the same way
when we get comments not everything that
is rooted in an opposing opinion of us
is necessarily a hater we realize that
some people disagree with us and it's
part of healthy debate so I don't like
the misc characterization of all
comments on our channel having common
haters mmm they're either trolls or
haters but there's not that many
what I mean I gotta hate her is gonna be
someone that's gonna bash us
consistently like you guys ain't doing
it and then you stay there all right
like nobody's obliging you to watch it's
like you subscribe you follow but just
the trash there's nothing just one thing
and you make it out of your way to say
something negative out of this but it's
not a lot of people that a lot of people
just don't like yeah that's perfect yeah
to see if they'd be interested in
talking with me face-to-face neither one
of us really knows who's on the other
side and maybe that's the problem part
of me wishes she would have contacted us
cuz I think we are your number one yeah
but we don't comment on it not that
written of the page but they know you
know I don't we done like 10 videos on
them yeah they're living rent-free in
our heads
first one to like the meanest one
alright well I give terrible people more
of a platform to talk about that
disgusting POS seriously Jubilee what
are you doing I guess anything for the
views huh oh okay
I'm literally frozen it-it's been 10
minutes and I have not even commented oh
my god okay it almost feels like she's
never scrolled to the comment section of
another channel that's not hers she's
never don't have social media she never
read comments ever like none like when I
started this YouTube stuff I wasn't
surprised when we got negative comments
I was like I can't believe this is
making me stop like no I've seen other
people go through it I've been to
comments sections I'm not surprised when
it happens to me so it seems a little
delusional
yes I'm doing great things I'm going
great things all the time
ya know even if you do great things all
the time people are gonna bash you
that's right you put yourself out there
is never shown I did I never fully
fleshed down no meaningful conclusion is
met everyone leaves the discussion
having not nothing but that's not wrong
though it's not bashing you maybe you
should think it as criticism yeah for
example when you had the men's rights
activist versus the family why did you
have an insult there why did you have
someone who really can articulate their
points
I feel empathy for women being lost
being this guy look there is nothing
more disinterested then try to have a
discussion on a topic with somebody who
doesn't know the parameters of that
topic
imagine having to discuss metaphysics
with someone who's never been to a
science class it's uninteresting and so
for your viewers we watch this that
we're like I think I got Dumber like
imagine talking metaphysics with someone
I've never been to a science class and
I'm like imagine talking metaphysics
with me so long in it hurts my heart I
just keep saying this is a horrific a
horrific way to handle this let me read
the comment this episode is very hard to
watch and I don't think it's an issue
like this can be tackled with such a
small sample size of people with little
with so little time it was honestly
super uncomfortable to watch and I
thought it was a horrific way to handle
the subject man
Weinstein is far too serious and
variable for people to break it down
into black and white not only that but
it's important to set a precedent by
stealing hard facts it is objectively
true that there is a global epidemic of
Weinstein against women and feminine
presenting people very inclusive of you
Brian good it is also objectively true
that men are significantly more likely
to be the perpetrators of one scene in
cases against all forms of individuals
no matter their gender expression very
very inclusive
it is also objectively true that the
majority of one stating cases do not
land in a conviction and if they do the
overwhelmingly affect people I would
give you an A plus plus but in a real
inclusive world we don't grade people
because all people are perfect but where
is that well you already know that is
the
superficial layer which is the top layer
where privilege really shines yeah it's
also objectively true that most
Weinstein cases go unreported all of
these things and more should have been
strongly been expressed by Jubilee and
as a fan of the show I'm extremely
disappointed by this negligence hater
okay this is what it is you have to be
able to look at yourself and right now
you're not looking at yourself you're
not you don't introspect at all it's
like there's not one insult in there the
person was able to to dissect and tell
you exactly what was wrong with the
thing I mean that is the best coming
that you can have on one everything that
one makes me want to like cry and like
lay down there's something about the two
episode that's like kind of horrifying
for me to tackle something that like
means so much to me and put so much work
into it and then have it be perceived as
negligent it's really really hard
it's so weird it like takes you back to
being like a kid where you like what the
bully don't like you like wait wait do
you think you're the only person who
this means a lot to you can't imagine
that it means a lot to other people I
thought because you mean a lot to you
that you can't mess up that you did and
ask my fellow Jubilee directors to chat
with me about their experiences with the
comment section with like some of my
more recent middle grounds like when I
did like men's rights versus feminists
and I cast it in in so yeah that was you
go of you yeah that's trash there are so
many dislikes and so many negative
comments on that video but that's like
one of the most proud videos I've ever
made it as an audience member if you're
only willing to watch things that
confirm what you already find to be true
then that's just like the most boring
poem that I've ever heard are you doing
it on purpose
did you just Gaslight everyone who
criticized you do you not understand how
you may have misrepresented the men's
rights movement by sticking and insel
who can't articulate his points imagine
if I tried
have a discussion between let's say
Israel and Palestine and I used a bunch
of toddlers do you think he'd be the
most productive conversation I have two
year-olds talking about it there's so
many times where like all the comments
are like damn I'm here too early there's
no funny comments and I'm like wow
really like half of your experience here
is just scrolling maybe not even
watching the actual video you see the
irony no she said here they are
complaining about the comments on the
videos that they're getting and how
they've read through the minute hurts
them and then they're complaining that
other people are doing the exact same
thing that they're doing yeah there's a
lack of a lot of things tell you that
much I was going to FaceTime my Eider in
three days after we confirmed my
FaceTime with Bryce we got a couple
other responses including one from the
guy critiquing our series middle ground
[Music]
only the voice only and preferably using
Google Hangouts vaguely spooky okay this
was my first time ever speaking directly
to a hater I had no idea what to expect
[Music]
hello hi hi this is Bonnie from Jubilee
can I start by asking just like your
name I don't know your name or anything
I go by wool flannel oh yeah I go by
fluffy buff the opposite of what this
guy is he's super friendly no I mean I
get it I would answer the same thing
this is the wool flannel thing well I'm
curious you know what sort of prompted
the video about our series the middle
ground
there's a good videos I was watching
that and you American yours a special
kind of over there so idea of giving
people platform to speak and something
good coming from that I think that's
that's a bit of an illusion like it
can't happen do you not think that in
order to empathize you have to like have
those human interactions and
conversations I have empathy for all of
these people understand it but it
doesn't make it less stupid if I were
doing videos that way it would be more
of these are why the Conservatives are
wrong or these why these people are
wrong and trying to get them from that
place where they're wrong and get them
to being right yeah I mean his idea was
also trash but I think one thing that
like we struggle with right is that the
Jubilee as a company doesn't want to
like take a side
you know like deem any one is like right
or wrong okay it's a noble choice but
there were winners and losers in life
right so you're being willfully ignorant
we're being willfully ignorant for not
acknowledging who's wrong or right yes I
know we're all social distancing but
this man got up in her face and whipped
out her soul yo he way he is damn yeah
damn yo some people are touched by an
angel she got touched by wool flannel
I'm supposed to be talking to brace
today really kept pressing snooze on my
alarm cuz I was like oh god I don't want
to do this waiting room
hello you're me
oh I can hear you oh yeah I'm good hurry
yeah I feel like I'm watching a first
date was really surprised he was a yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I'm fearful that he's gonna be like
a guy who's like really intelligent
who's like ready to wage war and is
gonna just kind of like spout a bunch of
facts at me and be like trying to win a
conversation you mean a guy giving you
proper context so that you can do things
not on emotion but on facts sounds
terrible sounds so bad oh my god hello
you know oh I can hear you oh yeah I'm
good how are you nice new to this off my
[ __ ] Bryce he knows what he's doing
yeah about that we switch to the words
they know why I'm talking like include
that PP yeah let's go I'd love to just
like kind of know a little bit about you
before we get into it yes I just
describe myself as like you're gonna
learn introverted nerd I used to
describe myself as a freelance artist
now I'm in IQ um that is my day job I
lived in Philly for like five years
yo listen we're not trying to find
points in common yeah
oh I owe you live in Philly I lived in
Philly yo what are you doing
what are you doing all right get to the
juice what's wrong with your videos now
get to the juice we want to learn
something
all right let's let's see what the hater
has to say I mean I love trees that's
another cool thing about me that's great
because you know what I do do you know
my go-to question is what if you were a
tree what kind of tree would you be
one of those lean first date questions
that they have on like things to ask
your girl I know cuz I used to ask this
when I was 18 it kind of tree would you
be
or I'd be like I'd be like if you could
choose between being a tree or a bird
which one would you choose and if you
choose to be a trooper that means that
you want to fly and be free and travel
the world you're gonna be a tree means
you wanna provide for your community and
blah blah Blee oh oh that's awesome
okay so if I were a tree [ __ ] just give
her your trunk and we can all move on
from this conversation because this is
weird I think the reason why I had such
a strong reaction to your comment to
feel like I've done a disservice to a
community that I'm trying to represent
or give a voice to I've been ruminated
on that thing for days like I was so
depressed after it came out because I
started seeing like the comment section
was very kind of icky and like yeah okay
well I do want to say something for you
thinking about
yeah good your video was important your
video was good and if you do feel hurt
by what I said I'm sorry that's not my
intention I'm not a troll I'm not trying
to hurt people I've had a difficult life
I've been through physical I figure you
running on dial-up what's that noise be
how do you work an IT and yours sounds
like it's from 1998 Windows 95 are you
frying bacon in there but no you look
great today agree with
anything he had to say it's funny I was
so nervous leading up to it and then I
was immediately at ease with him a lot
of like elements of our story really
similar I didn't tell them but I also
like my mom survived cancer too so like
she is a lot of where my focus has been
lately with like co-ed I wish I had said
that to him
I'm sad I didn't say that to him June
there's Hill was exactly what they're
talking about that you believe videos we
didn't learn a thing no other than you
like fig trees and you want to be one
it's like how to get a friends would
have extra steps yeah listen I don't
know tell you you're too fragile for
this stuff it seems in like you weren't
able to take the criticism well and he
wasn't able to say that same criticism
to you to your face that's the truth he
was being kind and compassionate and I
was trying to beat around the bush but
the first guy didn't care and it made
for a more interesting conversation
agree so I just have a big problem with
people labeling every negative comment
hey directed at them as hate no it's not
sometimes it's just an accurate take or
sometimes it's just good criticism and
good criticism is helpful it's not
because it makes you feel negatively
that it's inherently bad maybe you need
to get your ego out of the way and
accept it I know I've had to do it so
many times in my life so right now if
you want to do videos alright if you
want to do videos or any parts that you
put out there anything that you put so
far up and call it art but whatever
anything that you produce and you put
out there and it's open for criticism
you're gonna get criticized whether you
want it or not whether you ask it or you
did you're gonna get criticized it's not
for everybody yeah yeah there's a whole
lot of oh yeah you get recognized you
get this you get that people say yeah
it's not all all great and all good and
all funny some people are made for that
some people aren't that's a fact if
you're fragile if it really hurts you if
criticism hurts you feeling because X Y
Z booboo
do yourself a service don't do it yep
cuz it's gonna affect your mental and
yeah that's not so that's it for today's
video
tell us what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear what kind
of tree you might be so that's it for
today
[Music]
what do you feel like makes sense like
what do you feel like does work a lot of
time to learn the hard way you need to
be more aggressive you need to add you
need the attacks through the data we
have on these young people Amazon eBay
Facebook keep having arguments and
fights when we need to do is right there
in front of you where you were you
surprised when I reached out to you
about this no I suspected you would have
one of you would have washed there by
this point because I know my video is
good ayyy okay big energy in the house
that's right that's funny listen you've
watched and you were supposed to learn
he's not entirely wrong I feel like a
lot of times when people have these
conversations they do everything by
patting everyone's feelings and trying
to make it as palatable for everyone and
sometimes it's good to just be like
these are what the facts are your
feelings are your feelings but they
don't change what the reality is if beef
like Isabel from HR it's all bad but you
can't you know ah in in the kitchen
right we have a fool about certain
spices yeah yo that's Amin you could
it's a bit aggressive knock it off
that's it the same conversations gonna
take in 30 seconds I appreciate you
chatting with me and voicing your
opinions and your critiques I think on
some of these we'll have to agree to
disagree
I'll change your mind down the line you
just won't realize it no there's more
but you just like tender yeah oh yeah
I'm about to bag this on the box back to
spare
I was Moby Dick I energy exactly how was
Mira I'm gonna chain
your mind more than that I'm gonna blow
it no your mind blow your mind away it
sounds like you wants to blow some other
things straight oh oh what did you tell
me just what data yep you guessed it all
right thanks for chatting with me today
bye bunny
bye weird that's what people don't get
is they think that we are like sitting
in this super fancy media office like
commanding our army of you know like
interns and minions and then in the
meantime we're like snorting and like I
don't think that's what people think
they just think that you're doing bad
things
listen most youtube videos are made in
some dudes basement or bedroom okay and
guess what
those people receive the exact same
amount of criticism as you you're not
special
we don't think you're special we just
think that sometimes you make extremely
trash content yeah that's it and then
they have no idea that we are sleep
deprived usually like scarfing like
yesterday's leftover Panda Express deep
in the credit card debt it's not that
the imagine that they don't care has
nothing to do with the fact that your
video was trash all those kids that you
think that teenager that are in there
experiencing the same thing with their
everyday life you got exactly stuff like
that so being deprived of whatever I
mean if you fail a test the next morning
you still fail the test you understand
so yeah you sleep-deprived but you drop
the bomb